>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> James Wintle: Okay, so
my name is James Wintle.
I am a reference librarian here
at the Library of Congress.
And what I, I had a bit of
a change of heart recently
about what exactly I was
going to do in this program.
Initially, I was going to
give a moderately interesting,
but possibly boring lecture
about persil [phonetic].
And as I was researching the history
of early music at the Library
of Congress and the performances
of Congress, I came
across something of a gem.
And that particular gem
happened on, yes you guessed it,
November 29th and 30th in 1962.
And what happened on that particular
day, or evening as it were,
is that the actor Basil Rathbone,
yes the perplexed looks are
appropriate, came to the library,
and with an Elizabethan broken
consort, gave a performance
in which he read Elizabethan
poetry and monologues
from Shakespeare's plays,
interspersed with Elizabethan music.
And it's quite stunning and quite
interesting, and not the sort
of thing that one hears
these days at all.
So I decided to cast off
my delusions of grandeur
about giving a personal lecture, and
let everyone hear this thing that is
so unique and so interesting
and something
that really just would
not happen were it not
for the Library of Congress.
The concert series here is a bit of
a unique animal in and of itself,
and every once in a while, we have
these performances that really,
you just couldn't, you just
couldn't get anywhere else
because no other concert series
is also associated with the Center
for Poetry that can co-sponsor
such a thing and put it on.
So I wanted to give
everyone a unique experience
that you really just couldn't get
everywhere else, or anywhere else.
And encourage you to go read
more about persil [phonetic]
and you'll probably hear all
the boring stuff I was going
to say anyway.
So, that being said, just a little
bit about the concert series,
for those of you who don't know,
we're celebrating the 90th
anniversary of concert series.
It was founded in 1925 by
the, under the patronage
of Elizabeth Sprague Coolidge who
had had a chamber music festival
in the Berkshires, and wanted her
work as a chamber music patron
to live on after her death.
And decided that in order to
do that, she needed to partner
with a cultural institution
that had the longevity
that a person obviously
doesn't have.
So she picked the Library
of Congress, she was friends
with the person who was the
head of the music division
at that time, Carl Engel.
And many of you have
heard this before,
but I'll just give this little
overview for those you who haven't.
She was friends with Carl Engel and
her partnership with him enabled her
to work out the details, to donate
money to build the auditorium
in which you're going to hear
the concert this evening.
And there was famously an act of
Congress that had to be passed
in order for that to happen
because it was unprecedented
that someone would donate a large
amount of money to the government
for a building project just
because they felt it was
the right thing to do.
That sort of thing just
didn't really happen,
and still doesn't really happen.
And so we have this beautiful
chamber music auditorium thanks
to the generosity of
Elizabeth Sprague Coolidge.
And she is someone that we like to
remember often in the music division
because she sponsored so
many wonderful commissions.
Especially mid 20th century, she
was commissioning great works
from Aaron Copland, from Bela
Bartok, from Arnold Schoenberg,
from basically any
composer that you can think
of that really made an impact.
Prokofiev, you know, just everyone
was writing music to be performed
in this hall and we continue
that tradition today.
This season I think there are six
new premiers, it's in the booklet.
You can check my facts on that.
But it's a wonderful series,
and giving a little history
of that series I thought
was important,
particularly as it
regards early music.
Because there have been
so many commissions
and so many important commissions
that have been premiered here,
and new works that have
been premiered here.
It is often forgotten that
even from the beginning,
the beginning of this
concert series,
early music was very
much a part of it.
And there have been
concerts, a number of concerts
over the years by, for
insistence, the New York Pro Musica
with Noah Greenberg
has done medieval
and renaissance music
here a number of times.
Alfred Deller famously gave a
recital here in the late fifties.
And Mrs. Coolidge not only
commissioned new works,
but also commissioned
modernizations of early music.
And these are things that we,
I mean I've never actually
heard them performed,
but if they could be
performed sometime,
they will be performed here,
not anyplace else, I'm sure.
But there are, there are these
little corners of the collection
of manuscripts that she
donated to the library.
Like for example, orchestrations of
the luli arias [assumed spelling],
by the American composer Roy Harris.
Who she commissioned to orchestrate
these luli arias [assumed spelling]
for a performance in
the Coolidge auditorium.
And so the co-mingling of early
and modern music is something
that has a strong history here.
And it's the early part of it
that we will enjoy this evening,
first in this concert,
and then of course
with [inaudible] singing a
beautiful, beautiful program.
So what we will deal with
today crosses over a bit
with the earliest part
of her program.
And we're going to be listening to,
in particular, Elizabethan music.
And many of you, I'm sure,
know Elizabeth the first was
quite an active lover and patron
of music herself, and
was quite a good dancer.
And the idea of, or the corpus
of dance music that came
out of her reign was quite
spectacular, as well as wonderful,
you know, sacred music and
all the other things that we,
that we hear from that time.
One of the great composers
of the day, who we're going
to hear later this
evening, was John Dowland.
And he is featured on the
program we're going here
in just a moment as well.
He was not, he was a very, he
was a very well-known composer
particularly in England,
particularly in Europe,
but never was able to get a
position at the Elizabethan court.
So he was constantly
striving to gain the attention
of Elizabeth and of the court.
And so when you hear pieces on
the program tonight like the Earl
of Essex Galliard, it's turned
into a song and different pieces
by Dowland that have a little
bit of a political bench to them.
It's because he is trying
to gain that attention.
And he worked actually in
Denmark for Christian the fourth,
but published all of
his music in London.
And that is the real telling
element of his career,
that even though he was
working in Europe, he made the,
he made the trip, he made
the effort to come to England
and publish his works there
so they would be disseminated
amongst the people
and become the popular music
of the day that it really was.
And people talk about John
Dowland as being a kind
of folk musician of his day.
And it really is true, even though
he was writing very sophisticated
music, he was writing popular music.
And that's something that
a lot of people, I think,
have lost because we today, think
of concert music as one thing
and popular music as another.
When in fact, that's only something
that has happened in the past,
you know, hundred years, hundred and
fifty years really, that the music
that important composers were
writing was not really thought
of as popular, but in
the Elizabethan era,
it's very much that way.
And so, if you look at your
program and you think, oh well,
why is there, why are
there these pieces by Simon
and Garfunkel at the end, right?
It is in fact because that
is the modern equivalent
of what John Downland was
doing in the Elizabethan era,
much more so then songs
by, you know,
John Adams, or something like that.
It's, it really is that, that one,
that side of what Dowland was doing
that is important to represent
and important to remember.
So that will happen
later, that being said.
The pieces on this program
are for broken consort.
And that is not a reference to the
fact that the lute was very easy
to break, when in fact it was.
But, a broken consort is
a group of instruments
that are not all of the same kind.
A consort of instruments,
in the Elizabethan parlance,
is a group of different size
instruments of the same kind.
For instance, a consort of
recorders, a consort of lutes.
There were treble lutes, there
were bass lutes, and in between.
But a broken consort which became
a standard instrumentation was a
little bit of a few things.
It was a treble viol,
and a bass viol.
A treble viol, bass viol,
lute, this is the dulcian
which could be doubled as a flute.
This is actually a, no it's not
a dulcian, it's a bass recorder.
So it could be either
one of those recorders.
This is a bandora which
was also called pandora.
If anybody listens to an app called
Pandora, you have your music on it,
you can think of bass
string instruments
from the Elizabethan era the
next time you turn it on.
But the pandora or bandora,
and this was basically a bass
lute-like instrument.
The cittern, which looks
quite a lot like a mandolin,
except it has this
curved head on it.
And the cittern is interesting
because it had steel strings.
And it was one of the few of these
older Elizabethan instruments
that did not have gut strings.
So it had a really bright, sort
of a cutting tone in the ensemble.
And then of course you
have the standard lute.
So two viols, treble
and bass, flute,
and then three plucked
instruments, the bandora,
he cittern, and the lute.
And this became a fairly
standard consort.
Within Elizabethan times, there were
of course many variations on that.
Any number of instruments could
be a part of a broken consort,
as long as they weren't
just all the same thing.
There were often virginals or
other keyboard instruments,
and you'll hear some virginal music
in the program that is put on,
that we're going to listen to.
But this particular core group
of instruments is what is thought
of as that particular consort.
And this comes, it's
sort of solidified
in syntagma musicum of Praetorius.
This is the standard for modern,
modern players who are looking back
and trying to figure out what, how
these instruments work together
and how music was performed.
This particular treatise, which is
in three volumes, is
critical for that.
Another place in which the broken
consort appears, and you get a sense
of what exactly it was for, is in
an anonymous painting from 1596,
called the birth and
death of Sir Henry Unton.
And this is a strange
painting that is
in the portrait gallery in Britain.
And after Henry Unton
died in the 1590s,
his wife commissioned an unknown
artist to paint this piece
that depicted him, death, and an
angel on either side of his head
and he's writing because he
was a scholar and a statesman.
And then within the painting are
ten different themes from his life,
important things that
happened to him.
So it's kind of a biography
of this person.
And one of these scenes, which is
here, depicts a group of musicians
at an Elizabethan banquet.
And you see people eating
here, there's a room
with people playing cards
and they have [inaudible],
and they're sitting
around this table
with a little kid who's
doing something,
I'm not sure why he's there.
Then down here, you have another
group as similar to this group,
but obviously they're people,
and they're in the main sort
of dinning hall where
this is happening.
And there are these weird sort
of red-faced people walking next
to each other, and I'm not
sure what that's about.
There's a whole procession of these
guys, some candles, these guys,
some candles, and then some
more oddly-dressed folks
who I assume are a theater troop
because they're going up here
by the table to, I assume, entertain
people, and be much smaller
in scale than the actual table.
So, that's a [laughing]
just something that happens
in paintings at that time.
But anyway, so you have this
particular view of a broken consort
in action, and you have the flute,
the two viols, the cittern, Pandora,
and lute in a circle, there
and then again, up at the top.
So there is that, and then there is
the first book of consort lessons
of Thomas Morley, which was
a very important publication
for consort songs, and
consort music in the time.
And this publication, which says,
if you probably can't read
it, if you're very far back.
But it says the first book
of consort lessons made
by diverse exquisite authors for
six instruments to play together,
the treble lute, the pandora,
the cittern, the bass voile,
the flute, and the treble voile.
And it goes on to say things
about how gentlemanly they'll
be when they play them.
But this particular publication
is what inspired the consort group
to put on the concert
that we are going to hear.
There was a copy of this
book from 1599 that had come
into the library's possession, and
they were inspired by that to put
on a concert of Elizabethan music.
And as I said, Basil Rathbone who
did not play violin in the concert,
but rather as Sherlock
Holmes, which is great.
He was the person who they
picked to come and be the actor
in that particular, in that
particular presentation.
And this is the program
of the concert,
as you see it was the
Whittall Foundation
and the Whittall Poetry
Foundation and Literature Fund
which sponsored the concert.
So what we're going to do, we're
going to listen to a bit of this,
in the twenty-fiveish sort
of minutes we have left.
And we're going to
start with, let's see,
if music and sweet poetry agree.
So we're going to skip
a bit of the first part,
and be about halfway
down on the second page.
But I'm going to go to
the text, so you can hear.
Yeah, so at the bottom
here is where we'll start.
It says if music and sweet
poetry agree, as they must,
needs the sister and the brother.
Then must the love be
great towards thee and me.
Because thou loves the
one, and I the other.
Dowland, to thee is dear,
whose heavenly touch upon the
lute doth ravish human sense.
And you'll hear what happens
when he mentions John Dowland.
Since I'm probably not giving too
much away, but slight spoiler alert,
some music is played by the
many other people on stage.
So Mike, Mike if you could start the
festivities, I would appreciate it.
Thanks.
>> If music and sweet poetry
agree, as they must meet,
the sister and the brother.
Then must the love be
great, twixt thee and me.
Because thou loves the
one and I the other .
Dowland [string instrument playing
in background] to thee is dear,
whose heavenly touch, upon the
lute doth ravish human sense.
Spenser to me, whose
deep conceit is such.
As passing all conceit,
needs no defence.
Thou lov'st to hear the sweet
melodious sound of Phoebus' lute,
the queen of music makes.
And I in deep delight,
am tearfully drowned.
When as himself to
singing he betakes.
One god is god of both,
as poets feign.
One knight loves both,
and both in thee remain.
[ Music ]
If music and sweet poetry agree,
as they must needs the
sister and the brother.
Then must the love be
great, twixt thee and me.
Because thou loves the
one, and I the other
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> Music from the Elizabethan era.
We heard soprano Helen Boatwright
in "Where Griping Griefs"
by Richard Edwards.
And Basil Rathbone reading
Richard Barnfield's, "If Music
and Sweet Poetry Agree", to
the music of John Dowland.
Concluding this group was an
instrumental mask by Thomas Morley,
from his "First Book of Consort
Lessons" published in 1699.
Morley's book was the original
inspiration for this concert,
which was devised and
directed by Sydney Beck.
For many years, the music
editor and research librarian
at the New York Public Library.
Mr. Beck made a critical edition
of Morley's anthology as part
of his research into
Elizabethan consort literature,
and organized the consort
players to perform it.
His interest in the
relationship of this concert music
to Elizabethan poetry and drama
was shared by Basil Rathbone,
who collaborated with the consort
players for about two years.
Basil Rathbone begins this next
group of selections with a poem
by Ben Johnson, "Have You
Seen but a White Lily Grow."
Immediately following, you'll
hear an anonymous musical setting
of the same text for tenor and
flute, sung by Robert White.
>> Have you seen but
a white lily grow,
before rude hands have touched it?
Have you marked the fall of snow
before the earth has smutched it?
Have you felt the wool of
beaver or swan's down ever?
Or have smelt of the bud of the
brier, or the nard in the fire?
Or have tasted the bag of the bee?
Oh so white, oh so soft,
oh so sweet is she!
[ Singing "Have You Seen
but a White Lily Grow" ]
>> Tenor Robert White, and
lutenist James Tyler, "Have You Seen
but a White Lily Grow", an anonymous
setting of Ben Johnson's poem.
Basil Rathbone continues now with
a sonnet by William Shakespeare,
"How Oft When Thou My
Music", recited to a Fantasia
for virginals by Orlando Gibbons.
Blanche Winnigran [assumed
spelling] is the virginal's player
in this selection, and the
Scotch jig which follows.
[ Music ]
>> How oft when thou, my
music, music play'st. Upon
that blessed wood whose motion
sounds with thy sweet fingers
when thou gently sway'st. The wiry
concord that mine ear confounds.
Do I envy those jacks
that nimble leap,
to kiss the tender
inward of thy hand.
While my poor lips which
should that harvest reap,
at the wood's boldness
by thee blushing stand!
To be tickled, they would
change their state and situation
with those dancing chips.
O'er whom thy fingers
walk with gentle gait,
making dead wood more
bless'd than living lips.
Since saucy jacks so
happy are in this,
give them thy fingers,
me thy lips to kiss.
[ Applause ]
>> I often wonder how
Henry the eighth, you know,
[inaudible] [audience laughing],
ever managed to play one
of those things [audience laughing].
Well, it's so true that
his daughter Elizabeth,
played and played them very well.
Also her rival, Mary,
Queen of Scotts.
Can you hear her playing
the Scotch jig?
Most fitting as Will Shakespeare
says, "wooing, wedding,
and repenting, is as a Scotch jig,
a measure, and a cinque-pace."
The first suit is hot and hasty
like a Scotch jig, and
full as fantastical.
The wedding, mannerly
modest, as a measure,
full of state and ancientry.
And then comes repentance,
and with his bad legs,
falls into the cinque-pace,
faster and faster,
till he sinks into his grave.
Blanche dear, let's have
a good ol' Scotch jig.
[ Playing Scotch jig ]
[ Applause ]
>> James Wintle: Blanche Winnigran
[assumed spelling] was the
virginal's player in the
two works we just heard.
A Scottish jig by an
anonymous composer,
and earlier a fantasia
by Orlando Gibbons.
Our program turns now to Elizabethan
attitudes on the subject of love.
In these selections by John Dowland,
Thomas Campion, and Thomas Ford,
the scene is pastoral,
arcadian, and lighthearted.
First is Dowland's "The
Shepherds' Delight."
Followed by Robert Greene's
"Sweet Are The Thoughts That Savor
Of Content, the Quiet Mind
Is Richer Than A Crown."
Campion's "It fell
on a Summer's Day",
is followed by Christopher
Marlowe's famous poem,
"The Passionate Shepherd
To His Love",
and Sir Walter Raleigh's
"The Nymph's Reply."
Thomas Ford's "Sigh No More,
Ladies" ends this group.
[ Singing "The Shepherd's Delight" ]
>> Sweet are the thoughts
that savour of content.
The quiet mind is richer
than a crown.
Sweet are the nights in
careless slumber spent.
The poor estate scorns
fortune's angry frown.
Such sweet content, such
minds, such sleep, such bliss.
Beggars enjoy, when
princes oft do miss.
The homely house that
harbors quiet rest,
the cottage that affords
no pride nor care.
The mean that 'grees
with country music best.
The sweet consort of
mirth and music's fare.
Obscured life sets
down a type of bliss.
A mind content both
crown and kingdom is.
[ Singing "It fell
on a Summer's Day" ]
[ Applauding ]
>> Come live with me and be my love,
and we will all the pleasures prove.
That valleys, groves,
hills, and fields, woods,
or steepy mountain yields.
And we will sit upon the rocks,
seeing the Shepherds feed
their flocks, by shallow rivers
to whose falls, melodious
birds sing madrigals.
And I will make thee beds of roses,
and a thousand fragrant posies.
A cup of flowers, and a
kirtle embroidered all
with leaves of myrtle.
A gown made of the finest wool,
which from our pretty lambs we pull.
Fair lined slippers for the cold,
with buckles of the purest gold.
A belt of straw and ivy buds,
with coral clasps and amber studs.
And if these pleasures
may thee move,
come live with me, and be my love.
The shepherds' swains
shall dance and sing
for thy delight each May morning.
If these delights thy mind
may move, then live with me,
and be my love [applause].
If all the world and
love were young,
and truth in every
shepherd's tongue.
These pretty pleasures
might me move,
to live with thee, and be thy love.
Time drives the flocks from
field to fold, when rivers rage
and rocks grow old, And
Philomel becometh dumb,
the rest complain, or cares to come.
The flowers do fade,
the wanton fields,
to wayward winter reckoning yields.
A honey tongue, a heart of gall, in
fancy's spring, but sorrow's fall.
Thy gowns, thy shoes, thy
bed of roses, thy cap,
thy kirtle, and thy posies.
Soon break, soon wither,
soon forgotten.
In folly ripe, in season rotten.
Thy belt of straw and ivy buds,
thy coral clasps and amber studs,
All these in me no means can move,
to come to thee and be thy love.
But could youth last,
and love still breed.
Had joys no date, nor age no need.
Then these delights,
my mind might move,
to live with thee, and be thy love.
[ Applause ]
[ Singing "Sigh No More, Ladies" ]
>> Elizabethan songs and
poems on the subject of love.
Performed by Basil Rathbone,
soprano Helen Boatwright,
tenor Robert White, and the
members of the consort players.
The musical selections were John
Dowland's "The Shepherd's Delight",
Thomas Campion's "It
Fell on a Summer's Day",
and Thomas Ford's "Sigh
No More, Ladies."
Basil Rathbone read
poems by Robert Greene,
Christopher Marlowe,
and Sir Walter Raleigh.
Basil Rathbone is remembered
today as a film actor.
He was admired for his appearances
in films like David Copperfield,
Anna Karenina, A Tale Of Two Cities,
and Captain Blood with Errol Flynn.
And for many people, he is still
unforgettable as Sherlock Holmes.
But years before the film era,
Rathbone was already famous
for his roles on the London stage.
He was a very fine
Shakespearean actor,
whose early stage career
included performances
of fifty-three Shakespeare roles.
Many of them, at the
Stratford on Avon Festival.
We'll hear him now in Romeo's
farewell speech at Juliet's tomb,
act five, scene three,
from Romeo and Juliet.
>> Oh my love, my wife.
Death, that has sucked
the honey of thy breath,
hath had no power yet
all thy beauty.
Thou art not conquered, beauty
is ensign yet is crimson
in thy lips and in thy cheeks.
And death's pale flag
is not advanced there.
Tybalt, liest thou there
in thy bloody sheet.
Oh, what more favor can I do
to thee, than with that hand
that cut thy youth in twain, to
sunder his that was an enemy?
Forgive me, cousin.
Ah, dear Juliet, why
art thou yet so fair?
Shall I think that
unsubstantial death is amorous.
And that lean, abhorred
monster keeps thee here
in dark to be his paramour?
Oh for fear of that, I
still will stay with thee,
and never from this palace
of dim night depart again.
Here, here will I remain with
worms that are thy chamber maids.
Oh, here will I take up my
everlasting rest, and shake the yoke
of inauspicious stars from
this world-wearied flesh.
Eyes, look your last.
Arms, take your last embrace.
And, lips, O you the doors of
breath, seal with a righteous kiss,
a dateless bargain
to engrossing death.
Come, bitter conduct,
come, unsavory guide.
Thou desperate pilot, now at
once, run on the dashing rocks.
Thy seasick, weary
bark, here's to my love.
Oh, oh true apothecary.
And thy drugs are quick.
Thus with a kiss, I die.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> James Wintle: Consort
lessons, which as you heard,
inspired this rather,
extraordinary program.
So you see in this program, I think,
the, really the link that was poetry
and theater and music, it really
is inseparable in this culture.
And when you listen to the pieces
from this era, which are just a few
on the, at the beginning
of the program tonight.
I hope that you are, that
you appreciate that and think
about it not only in the context
of what's happening on stage,
but also in the context of the plays
that you've read and the poetry
that you've heard and
the other experiences
of that culture that you've had.
And help it create a
larger context for the music
that speaks to you in that way.
So I hope that you enjoyed this, I
know it's a little different to sort
of just play a tape for people,
but I thought it was really worth
hearing, and I hope you did too.
And thank you all for coming.
It'll be about 10 minutes
until they open the house.
So you have a minute to do
whatever it is you need to do,
which we don't need to discuss.
And, so you'll have a little
time to get together and talk
about Elizabethan poetry
or whatever you need to do.
So does anyone have any questions
before we adjourn this meeting
of the Basil Rathbone appreciation
society [audience laughter]?
Oh I will add that when the
announcer was talking about his,
the great film credits
of Basil Rathbone,
he did leave out my two
favorite Basil Rathbone movies.
So I feel compelled
by pure hubris and ego
to tell you what my favorite
ones are, like you care.
And the first is, of course Robin
Hood, and his performance as Sir Guy
of Gisbourne in Robin Hood, the
great sword fight at the end
with Errol Flynn is unforgettable.
And the other that many of you may
not have seen, and this is specially
for the kids in the audience,
Universal Pictures made a number
of monster movies in
the, in the fifties.
And the Boris Karloff
Frankenstein was one the best,
one of my favorites.
The sequel to that everyone knows,
was the Bride of Frankenstein.
However, the third movie in that
series was the Son of Frankenstein.
And the Son of Frankenstein was the
last the one that had Boris Karloff
as the monster, and it
starred Basil Rathbone
as Victor Von Frankenstein's
son, Wolf von Frankenstein
and it is a brilliant film.
So if anybody likes monster
movies, check out Basil
in the Son of Frankenstein.
You heard it here first, or possibly
a number of times, I don't know.
But anyway, anyone have any
questions about the program
or about the concert
series in general,
or my apparent love
of monster movies?
Anyone have a questions?
Yes.
>> Just to be absolutely
sure about the dates,
it's 1599 because the
narrator said 1699.
>> Could you repeat that?
>> James Wintle: For the Morley?
>> Oh, the narrator on your
recording said 1699, but your slide
and your reference was 1599.
>> James Wintle: The Morley consort
lessons absolutely came out in 1599,
it's definitely not 1699.
That was, I know it's hard to
believe, but a mistake on the radio.
No, but I know, know what you mean.
But yes, 1599 absolutely
true, 1699 just misread it.
Anything else?
>> That only really seems to
work with the British accent.
>> James Wintle:[laughing]
There is a certain manner
of speech I think we're all used to.
I think, I think the
words are powerful enough
to really withstand any accent.
I could be proven wrong by that
fairly, with that fairly easily,
but I think of Shakespeare
especially
as a kind of unshakable genius.
In the same way that I think
of Johann Sebastian Bach,
I hear Johann Sebastian Bach
played on all sorts of instruments
that he never would have heard of.
And you can hear a Bach prelude
played on almost anything,
and it's still a brilliant
piece of music.
And I think that with this, you
can hear it spoken with any accent,
as long as the person
knows what it means.
And again, with the Bach, as long
as the person knows what it means.
But I don't think so, I don't think
it has to have a British accent,
I think we're just
used to it that way.
But I do see your point,
it works better that way
because it's more, it
seems more authentic.
And the, speaking of
authenticity in this program,
you heard the 1962
version of early music.
They were in fact playing on
replicas of early instruments,
but the singers, as none of us have
replicas of Elizabethan vocal cords,
they were going full bore
with the vibrato and all that.
And very much in, you know,
in the style of that time,
and these early music
recordings from that period,
you hear a very different
sound from the singers.
And in a certain way, they dig
into the music a little more
because they give it
more voice, you know?
And so there's a lot to
be learned from this.
I think as a singer, listening to
these, to these earlier recordings
where they're just really
discovering this music,
I think can be educational.
But a lot of the people, I was in
an early music program in college
and a lot of the people in that
program did not listen to this era
of early music recordings.
And didn't, you know, they, it was
wrong, and so they didn't do it.
But I think there's a lot to be
learned and I think that listening
to these early tries at, you
know, this music is, it is,
there's a lot to be said for it.
So I'm all for it.
Anyone else have questions?
[ Inaudible question ]
>> James Wintle: Yeah and if you
had, in the 19, the tale of scholars
in 1973 is very different than
the tale of scholars today.
And that whole sort of English,
English church coral sound
that influence what we think of
as what early music is supposed
to sound like is, to
a certain extent,
a twentieth century invention.
So you have to sort of
keep these things in mind.
Yeah, but that's, that's a
great group, I love those guys.
Questions, anyone else
have questions?
Yes.
>> Did they use a different print,
so we're used to the notes having
certain frequencies and scale today.
Back then were they
using a modulator
or somewhat different scale?
>> James Wintle: They were
using a different scale,
they were also using a
different pitch standard.
So what we think of as A440,
it was lower than that, and,
in England it was lower than that.
In parts of Italy, it was higher.
See people think about, I'm
glad we've left a little time
for questions because, and I'll
try not to go on about this,
but the idea of pitch standard
was a completely variable idea
until the 19th century.
And especially in the 17th
century, you've got pitch standards
at widely different ranges depending
on where you were in Europe.
So parts of Italy, it was
higher than we think of as A440,
it was like A460, other
places in Italy it was lower,
and Germany it was lower.
And because Bach's pitch standard
was A415, we think of A415 now
as baroque pitch, when in fact there
is no such thing as baroque pitch.
There's German baroque pitch,
which is A415, and that's what,
that's how we talk about that.
So and you, and we know that from
measuring the lengths of instruments
of organ pipes that still exist,
that sort of thing you can tell
what the pitch standard was
in any given time, from wind
instruments, that kind of stuff.
So there is that part of it,
and then there is also the
pitch standard is one thing,
and the temperament is another.
And the temperament means the
distance between the whole steps
and half steps in the scale.
So the actual frequency
difference, in today's standard,
is called equal temperament tuning,
which means in between every
half step is the same number
of frequencies, in
between each half step.
In the seventeenth century,
and in most times before
the nineteenth century,
that idea of temperament
was variable.
And so you had varying, because now
in equal temperament, as they say,
everything is equally out of tune.
There, and we're just used to
it so that's, it sounds fine,
but as far as how the frequencies
actually line up mathematically
to each other, pretty much
everything is out of tune.
And what they would do in
the seventeenth century
and in earlier times, they
would change the distances,
it was variable between
different half steps in the scale
so that particular keys, you could
play on a keyboard instrument,
particular keys were exactly
mathematically in tune.
And as you got further afield
from one or 2 sharps or, you know,
what have you, then it became
more and more dissonant.
And so the idea of dissonance
in this early music is actually
something that, unless you're sort
of in the early music scene, you
don't really tend to understand
because it's not only a half step
next to each other being dissonant,
but a half step that
is tuned differently.
Being closer together
possibly or further away,
in frequency that sounds
much more dissonant
than if you just play two notes
next to each other on a piano.
So it's a whole different way
of hearing music, and there's a,
this is a great time to dispel
a myth that is perpetuated
by music history that
sort of gets on my nerves.
Which is the idea that Bach
wrote the Well-Tempered Clavier
for a keyboard instrument that
was in equal temperament tuning,
that is in fact not true.
And he wrote preludes and fugues
in all of the keys to experiment
with a new type of tuning that
was in fact not equal temperament.
It was well-tempered and it
was some sort of variation
on what they call sixth
comma meantone.
And certain keys were in tune
and certain keys were not.
And the further afield
you get from C major,
the less in tune the actual key is.
And so when you play, for instance,
the B major prelude in fugue
in the well-tempered clavier,
it is purposely an
extremely dissonant piece.
They're much, there are
many more accidentals
and it's much more harmonically
adventurous because the key in
and of itself was going
to be dissonant.
And so those pieces
are written differently
if you really look at it.
Those pieces are written differently
than the, than the earlier ones
in the book because he was dealing
with this different tuning system.
So anyway, that is a whole
other lecture, but is something,
something that's interesting to
think about when you're listening
to this music because some people
go hear baroque orchestras,
and they think everything's
out of tune.
Because it's not what you're
used to, and as, you know,
people used to say, they're people,
you know, who have perfect pitch.
And then they get into early
music ensembles and they have
to develop different
perfect pitches, you know?
So they can sort of think in
A415 and that sort of thing.
But every you know, everyone says
that your perfect pitch is tuned
to your grandmother's piano.
So the whole idea of temperament
is variable, is what that means.
So anyway, other questions
about stuff in general,
or other things, music
related hopefully.
I tend to be able to answer
those questions more efficiently
than other subjects.
I don't know a lot about
plants, that sort of thing
for instance [audience laughter].
Yes.
>> I've never heard of a bandora
before, is there any difference
between it and a theorbo?
>> James Wintle: Yes,
there is a difference.
A theorbo is basically,
a slightly, well,
it depends on which theorbo you're
talking about, but it's basically,
a theorbo is basically a
lute with extra strings.
And so the lute is fairly standard,
and then there are extra bass
strings that are not fretted.
So you basically play
the bass strings
at whatever pitch you tuned
the string to like a harp,
and then play the lute like a lute.
A bandora is a fully
bass instrument, and the,
the, I'll just get to this.
As you see, the body of the bandora,
you can't really see it from here.
But the lute is rounded in the back,
which gives it a different sort
of resonance, the bandora is flat.
And so it's about that thick,
but flat on either side,
and then shaped [inaudible] with
a little curlicue at the top.
And it has double course
strings, like the lute does,
but is pitched much lower, and
has a different resonance quality.
Yes it's lower.
And it has the, it has a resonance
quality that's slightly more flat
than the lute because, because
of the shape of the instrument.
But the bandora that that we think
about as the bandora
is the bass bandora.
And that's what you hear
in the broken consort,
there were actually treble bandoras
in the Elizabethan era,
there were all sizes.
And in one of the treatise,
I don't remember which one,
but there's a treatise that talks
about different sizes of bandoras
and says that there is one
small enough to fit your pocket.
So I assume it's some sort of
large pocket, but it would be
like something like this.
So a soprano bandora is
something that existed,
I've never actually seen one,
I've only ever seen a bass,
but that's the essential difference.
Anyone else?
We're, time, alright.
Thank you all for coming,
I appreciate it very much,
for indulging my love of
Basil Rathbone [applause].
Thanks a lot.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.